aber nicht erkannt geworfen aber dann
verworfen wer jetzt noch eine ganze
reihe habe ich da gerade lover wie
verbinde alles was den anderen nutzen
könnte ich höre hier noch ein slime eine
lama bitte hier rein
ich höre erst mal noch ein slime bat ich
laufe weiterhin fette slime alter also
der baut sich hundertprozentig hinter
sich zu das ist klar jetzt ein mops
bonner der es aber schon ausgebaut
da sind zombies dass ein komischer
villages zombie vielleicht habe ich
diesen islam auch mit erde setzen
dann geht es um dich man die machen
einmal weiter blabla sich koblenz
irgendwas gedroppt gold läuft noch
welche vor nicht komm zurück
so sind wie wir sagen gehen wir raus
wenn die finden wir nicht mal wieder der
ist nie cage entlockt ihr wissensstand
raus
hier geht's dir außer sammer drei ist
ballack nur eine spitzhacke so viel
eisen rüstung wieder wann ich würde echt
gerne anders machen allerdings scheiße
santala sie angehen ich möchte echt sein
anbaus haben wir haben noch so viel ich
habe zwölf alle sind hier braucht man
denn man braucht drei mal neun los 4
wieso +4 was ist denn hier vier normale
reisen und vier eisen blöcke dauert bis
das leck cartel media genau jetzt weg
unten
hier hab ich denn direkt hier
der will nicht raus der bürger draus wer
die hosen voll okay okay okay
der bogen oder aber doch nicht taten
kant geworfen aber dann verworfen
er ist ein wasserstoff-leck ich dachte
ich folglich schlange ich habe dir
irgendwelche getränkepreisen blöcke
alter wir [ __ ] alle der eisenhütte der
diamant gehabt alter witz ok gerade erst
wieder nach dem ersten block ich kann
ihnen aber nicht einsammeln
da wartet dann inventar ist dann voll
nein ist nicht voll dass das problem
bald kommt einsammeln so ok wussten das
ist wieder nach darunter gehen lasst uns
wieder nach unten gehen liegt er noch
immer
ich habe mich hab mich haben lassen sich
nach dem gähn
lasst uns als eisen suchen und versuchen
sind auszumachen weil dieser in
schalteten büchern etwas hastig
aspiration protection drei organ körper
jeder dass eine verzauberung also ich
habe ein alter ich habe wurf fand der
schnelligkeit
das ist jetzt mal so ein neues links
aufbauen so kräftig tempo erstmal dahin
alter über 100 neue kist ich hab mir nur
scheiße oder macht macht man kräftig
kann ein bisschen holzkirchen was den
gästen kräftig ab holz findet sich laut
immer ganz kurz ein bisschen ein dass
ihr keiner hinkommt
ja mein ganzes inventar ist voll mit dem
ist ich kann uns im bogen machen sich
gerade den ganzen schrott hier rein
baulich nicht 2014 habe ich noch so ist
das verzauberte das brauche ich noch das
nicht ich hab ne tja mein spitzhacke
gefunden der leute kann man später
klappt ja ich hatte euch hab doch auch
eine der mann spitzhacke hat breite
riskierten auch diamant nach ihren
trotzdem weg gegeben hatte doch von
anfang an der diamant spitzhacke ach so
jetzt habe ich aber auch eine private
wie viel eisen haben wir ich habe ich
hab hier 21 reise und einen blog ich
habe ja ich habe 14 eisen im inventar 21
so kannst du im ofen machen
ich habe ihr der kiste ist auch noch
stein
okay ich habe offen setzen einfach mal
dahin
jetzt können die kids nicht mehr von
zwei sehr unklug knicks und offen bisher
es fehlt nur noch ein eisen wenn du mir
das geben kannst einen alten eisen und
dann nahm dann suche ich schnell 1
nicht so schon mal den rest weg anni
eingeplant ist meine ich natürlich nicht
ja ich habe auch noch 14 eisen so fällt
mir dann auf also nicht gebrannten also
geil ich hoffe auf jeden fall amboss ich
hab ich doch glatt gegeben ich brauche
erstmal ein bisschen zu nett dass sie
nicht an da hinkommen sortiere ich mir
nochmal alles und wie kohle trend so
zeigt das ist schon mal sexy import von
anderer seite zuerst auf dem zu wort als
waren doch noch ja deswegen da kommen
dann wenn schon können wir dann nachher
durch so ein eisen das wird sexy zeigt
schon mal genau was für bücher du hast
ich habe protection drei restoration 2
und protection 330 kilowatt viel viel
hass do 16 sep 20
ich weiß nicht wie viele diamanten hast
du ich hab zwei soll ich mir mal schuhe
machen oder protection draufpacken
ja was tun für eine andere verzauberung
also warte ich mal die bücher dahin das
aber ich habe auf deutsch englischen
sommer dann kann ich nichts anfangen
habt ihr mal oft liegen vor die ach so
da hab ich kein sechser pack dafür drin
atmung zwei das ist mist und schutz 33
kann man schon auf ihn wie schuhe packen
oder so ja ich habe ja es gibt du mir am
besten werden diamanten mache ich mit
diamant schule mit protection 3 und du
kannst es dann etwa auf deinen displayed
machen das macht dann glaube ich das
gleiche aus ich hab ja hier das ist ja
atmung was mir gegeben hast ich hab den
bauch protection alles gegeben
wer du hast einmal protection 3 gegeben
ach so das heißt dass diamanten schuld
ich mache die musik genau hast du ja gut
machen wir so ich habe nie diamanten
geworfen zackig mach dir nämlich auf
meine reisen brust ja ja genau dann hat
es mich die gleichen effekte alter ich
habe jetzt eine verzauberte eisen brust
verzaubert behoben
er gibt immer das denn es gibt immer die
protection wie das protection das buch
wieder verzaubert da waren zwei du hast
kein protection bücher mehr verzaubern
ich habe ihr konto hast doch schon eine
verzauberte hose alter das allgemein
viel mehr als nichts aber ich jetzt noch
meinem helm mit atmung das heißt
einatmung das bringt das auch so wenn
der kauf soll in mileys kann
einfach weil es kann ganz genau so cool
aus oft habe ich hier klappt es hat
nicht geklappt und selbst habt ja keine
ahnung vielleicht obwohl sie der amboss
ist manchmal buggy ich kenne das ja das
buch ist es noch ich habe ein ich habe
meine level verloren aber am besten wir
brauchen noch so ein buch wo man dann
war mir nicht 100-prozentig eine
verzauberung tisch weil lasst einfach
zurück wir haben doch alles da die haben
gläser bei uns in der ersten base wir
haben hier sind auch noch gläser jetzt
auch noch hinaus wir haben beide die am
anpacke wir haben lava wir haben diese
wir müssen nur obsidian finden haben
blaze rotter wir haben die anderen dinge
da das heißt wir können uns direkt an
den fahrzeugen zu können doch wir haben
auch bücher da ich hier sind also hast
diamanten ja schon verbraucht
ja faktisch machen können ist wird erst
mal für einen gefallen also auf jeden
fall bücher ich weiß vielleicht weißt du
wo hast du noch spinnweben
ich schreibe einfach auch wir laufen
auch um im jahr 2000 gegeben da mache
ich mir schon einen bogen
ich habe ein paar fehler ich habe aber
nur zwei ich habe einen selber gehabt
deswegen das reicht eigentlich genau das
habe ich nämlich schon mal wieder ein
bogen dass es mich schon ein bisschen
besser als nichts ich hab's ganz weiten
bogen gefunden sich gerade im hast du
viele
pfeile habe ich gar keine ich habe
welche da ich mache in 54 14 pfeile dann
halt einfach nur ich hab einen wurf
trank noch der nacht sich das habe ich
auch ich habe noch zwei mal müssen
irgendwo noch lava finden haben schon
einen lover immer aber ich habe auch
noch einen also deswegen reisen schwert
und den ganzen scheiß hier rein den ich
nicht brauche ok sowie stations täglich
das hier oder soll ich die zwei mal
zurück nicht aber sogar drei eimer
ich habe eigentlich bin komplett
ausgerüstet hier hast du noch mal ein
eimer falls ihr noch mal aber finde ich
hab auch zweimal im inventar ich habe
einen wurf lang der schnelligkeit und
wurst sagt der nacht sich noch im wollen
wir den amboss abbauen oder zumindest
irgendwie ein verstecken lebenden bäumen
einfach ab und ist mit sicherheit das
das ja nicht dass es noch mal findet
aber dass das vielleicht noch so machen
weil die ganze sache die hier sind ja
scheiße oder hier jetzt mal da die
larven und dann mach ich die kiste
kaputt wie soll ich da dabei einsetzen
damit ich dir ist kaputt machen alles
einfällt was soll er machen können
niemand mehr profit herausschlagen halte
das ist so dreckig was ich erwarten so
das nächste kannst doch hier drunter
eine setzen wir gar nicht so gut gemacht
sozial was wir machen
alternativ zwei reisenden abbauen
ok läuft wir mal 13 alten jetzt mit acht
ja die lava habe ich mitgenommen
ok firma weiter wenn wir das gewinnen
das war schon echt geil damit ich gar
nicht gerechnet ich bin schon
rausgegangen ja gut ich sehe dich nur
noch kurz was essen
ich habe bewusst schlank der
schnelligkeit und der nacht sich also
wenn du was brauchst sag bescheid ich
habe auch noch vier tenöre schnelligkeit
und nachts ich ganz normal bei dass hier
hinschmeißen einfach ich habe
okay ich habe jetzt auch noch jetzt
einfach herumlaufen und dann versuchen
in welche zu finden
aber ich habe auch viel tnt gefunden
also dass deine schuhe verzaubert mit
schutz
ja du brauchst eine tablette nicht auf
der brust mehr gleich viel oder ich hab
dir man im film was nun tick besser aber
dafür habe ich vorher das ist in soften
hosen da keiner drin war obwohl am
anfang gesagt hat das war schon so
offensichtlich und schwamm was ich
dachte war unsichtbar da kommt echt aus
dem nichts ich bin vergiftet er schaut
mich vergiftet dass hier sowohl privat
of phoenix diamant schwert komplett
verzauberte des faktors weg laufen ja
noch nicht was da wir fanden jetzt
wahrscheinlich ich hab's geschafft
ich bin tot sei und dass kann nicht sein
es stürzt ab in dem moment ja hans
bissing abstraktes
das kann doch nicht sein ich muss
irgendwie ich jedoch noch die kisten ist
und haben das jetzt gerade alles
verbrannt nein ich bin gestorben
unsere richtige kiste und dann geht es
geradeaus ich logge mich jetzt einmal
bin ich jetzt auch down oder was das
kann es doch nicht sein muss es jetzt
auch ausgehen so nicht nur wegen
vorschneller bin ja ich habe keine
chance ich war noch nicht mal eingeloggt
und schon dauern
das war wirklich scheiße das ist geil
das ist echt unfair gewesen habe ich ja
gar nix alter
naja verloren
wir waren so gut egal wer schon ein team
ausgerottet wir sind ja nicht so viele
teams also ich glaube gar richtung kiste
braucht ich laufe auch richtung gäste
dann treffen uns dann aber alles
verbrannt
die haben uns wirklich verzauberung zu
sparen sollten wir alles mit level 1
verzaubern zumindest ihr habt alles da
ich habe vergessen dass du nur die art
ist deswegen habe ich nicht dran gedacht
wieso konnten die sich immer ob man darf
sich porten wenn man stirbt irgendwo sie
erneut
ich glaube das kann man nie wieder
aufholen oder scheiße das schaffen wir
nicht mehr vor allem dienstag das ist
keine ahnung woher haben die die sache
näher als auf die das alles gefunden
haben die haben wie gesagt sich für
alles mit level 1 wahrscheinlich
fahrzeug aber das bringt schon wenn du
überall protection eins drauf hast
beispielsweise fragen wir hatten auch
genug eisen um alles mögliche zu
verzaubern und bücher aber auch genug
beispielsweise afag stimmt so
das heißt jeder hat ein leben gebraucht
das internet direkt tot
also wenn wir jetzt noch mal sterben
sind weg ich sehe nicht wo bist du
23 goblins ja ich kann mich mal zur
kasse und ich weiß ich hab mir da noch
reisen drin oder sowas nicht nötig nicht
kaputt runter
ja warte ich versuche die sachen zu
finden als ob sich goblins schaffst
ersten liga start etwas nicht wirklich
einfach hinunter gegraben
ja hier in der höhle reingegangen oder
gar nicht ich bin hat neun meter bei der
kiste und da glaube ich nicht komische
steine im weg dass man komplett
jawohl ich mache ich platt mit dem
kritischen fausthieb junge was genau
darunter wo ich bin an die warte warte
noch moment weil ich habe mich gerade
bei stein mit der hand runter das ist
relativ armselig aber na ja noch sechs
meter bis zur karl platt dauern ja ich
weiß wo die kiste ist ich bin ja hier
afag elvir schaffen dass er nicht mehr
mann das war ein guter start leider
fliegend der stadt hier hat man schon
gesehen hast dir alles schön geblufft
haben mit rwe diamanten
jeder von uns hat auch zweiten andy du
hast auch du hast jetzt haben die
verzauberte sachen gut verzauberte
sachen ach du scheiße du bist du gerade
irgendwie fast vollzählig im sleep modus
müsst mich doch hören oder nicht gerade
da bist du ich frag mich hier runter bei
den ganzen scheiß sachen unternehmen war
die ganze erde
ich habe allerdings seine okay an das
tempo durch
energie ist was haben wir denn so alles
noch wie wir uns auf keinen fall mehr
reisen ein gold schwert ich ziehe mir
diese länder pokern von null an
aber wir haben ja noch gold erstmal
ausgewichen
ich habe ja noch richtig machen sie mal
eisen schwerter du hast die eisen
ja ich mache das eisen schwerte wir
brauchen auf den preis hoffen ich habe
das geht nicht ich kann uns zwei helme
machen nachmittag helme machen
man macht mal mache alles aus holz gold
das auch noch gold in der kiste
4 ich möchte dazu das müssen wir
verbrennen weil ich habe nicht mehr
genug also hier ist noch ein helm
zumindest ich habe einen gold schwert
von anfang